christophe prudhomme qui est médecin
urgentiste au samu responsable cgt
l'adage on va vous retrouver tout à
l'heure bonjour un christophe prudhomme
est d'être en direct avec nous sur arte
france
comment vous réagissez à cette journée
d'action à paris particulièrement
émaillée par des heures d entre certains
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
écoutez ce qui est important c'est que
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont manifesté aujourd'hui
enfants dans 220 rassemblements physique
plus des manifestations dans les
hôpitaux les rassemblements pour nos
collègues qui est au travail et qui sont
rassemblés 20 à 30 minutes sur leur
temps de pause en ce qui concerne les
incidents à paris
écoutez moi j'aimerais bien que vous
médias vous posiez la question au préfet
l'allemand une préfète paris qui est
très contesté sur la raison pour
laquelle quelques dizaines quelques mois
j'étais sur la manifestation
ils étaient très peu nombreux ces
agitateurs
pourquoi la police les laisse agir pour
qu'ensuite dans les médias au lieu de
parler des revendications de la
manifestation vous fassiez vous tourner
en boucle sur les affrontements à la fin
de la manifestation
c'était ce qui s'était passé pour les
manifestations pour les retraites est là
de nouveau ça se pose pourquoi
quelles sont les consignes données à la
police moi je pose le problème on
regarde ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
années et de la position du préfet
l'allemand moi je fais partie de ceux
qui posent la question pourquoi ce
préfet reste en poste alors qu'il est
contesté et que régulièrement nous avons
des incidents et manifestations où la
police reste statique presse laisse ces
éléments brûler des voitures agir sans
interviennent au bon moment voilà moi
j'étais sur place et je pose cette
question et je remets en cause
effectivement les consignes qui sont de
l'impôt l'histoire secrète
christophe prudhomme vous pointez là et
c'est vrai une situation que l'on
observe dans bon nombre de
manifestations avec mes gilet jaune mais
pas seulement
on a vu que lors des dernières
manifestations contre les violences
policières et le racisme présumées au
sein des forces de l'ordre
c'était aussi compliqué c'est une
situation qui est récurrente mais c'est
aussi compliqué pour les forces de
l'ordre qui sont mobilisés soumis à rude
épreuve la rude épreuve
semaine après semaine ce qu'est ce
qu'ils foutent ils pointent et pointé
les responsabilités
je ne pointe pas les responsabilités des
policiers qui sont sur place
c'est pas le problème ils sont
effectivement mis dans des situations
très difficiles du fait des cendres qui
leur sont données voyez moi lors de
manifestations pacifiques
j'ai eu affaire à ces maps rigal volant
de policiers sur moto et quitter ce
n'est pas une police républicaine
voilà c'est ça le problème aujourd'hui
quelles sont les consignes qui sont
données à la police par le préfet
l'allemand pourquoi y at-il toujours des
incidents dans les manifestations avec
quelques dizaines parfois quelques
centaines d'agitateurs nous étions
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
manifestants
la manifestation s'est très bien passé
nous avons demandé la dispersion il
reste encore quelques personnes sur les
pelouse
il fait beau mais pourquoi
systématiquement y at il des incidents
qui permettent à bout médias de les
passer en boucle pour pouvoir parler
d'autre chose que de la journée d'action
très massives avec des revendications
qui sont précises concernant l'hôpital
c'est beaucoup plus important que ces
quelques incidents
nous demandons aujourd'hui ça fait trois
semaines qu'on vous amuse avec le
secteur de la santé nous demandons des
réponses du ministre et nous avons posé
un ultimatum ministre en tout cas nous
les organisations syndicales on doit
leur en gros on doit honda demandé qu'il
soit présent la place notamment non
cher et qui viennent avec des réponses
financièrement non au minimum 15
milliards d'euros immédiatement pour
répondre aux revendications concernant
les effectifs et les salaires sans
pareille sur d'importantes mais c'est ce
qu'a proposé le gouvernement il ya
quelques jours uniquement pour un
secteur d'activité qu'à l'industrie
aéronautique est ce que l'hôpital le
secteur de santé et d'action sociale
n'est pas aussi important que le secteur
aéronautique
et pourquoi le gouvernement ne nous
donne aucun chiffre
aucune somme aucun moyen supplémentaire
pour l'hôpital alors que ça fait trois
semaines que l'on participe à des pseudo
réunion voilà la colère elle est là
après le problème de la police et du
préfet l'allemand crois que ça soit
réglé par le président de la république
par ministère de l'intérieur il ya un
véritable problème
christophe prudhomme qui vous parlez des
médias est vrai qu'on passe en boucle
ces images de manifestations et ses
heures mais c'est aussi l'occasion et on
l'a vu tout au long de cet après-midi
d'entendre aussi des manifestants et on
a mis aussi en avant ces manifestants
ainsi que leurs revendications c'est ce
que vous faites également puisque vous
parlez des des 15 milliards d'euros que
vous vous attendez le gouvernement ils
vous donnent rendez vous au mois de
juillet justement pour fixer les
modalités
les en tout cas donner des réponses aux
questions que vous vous posez et que
tous les partis serait dans le pose à ce
gouvernement là concrètement vous vous
attendez vous au mois de juillet des
réponses concrètes
non mais juillet c'est trop tard nous
avons déjà prévu deux nouvelles journées
d'action parce que nous sommes dans
grève depuis un an un an
les quatorze gouvernement s'ils nous
donnent pas de réponse c'est qui veut
pas nous donner une réponse
donc c'est que c'est non donc nous
allons nous avons déjà prévu
donc j'en ai l'action je pense qu'ils
seront encore plus puissante que celle
d'aujourd'hui
le 30 à la fin du mois et le 14 juillet
parce que nous n'acceptons pas nous
n'acceptons pas que monsieur macron nous
instrumentalise en lui proposant de
défilés ou d'aller une sauterie le 14
juillet nous nous serons présents le 14
juillet sur les champs-elysées
aux blues pour dire monsieur macron ce
ne sont pas des médailles que nous
voulons ce ne sont pas des cérémonies
des seuls au défilé du 14 juillet ce
sont des réponses à leurs demandes
ication nous ne sommes pas des héros
nous sommes les salariés qui demandent
ont des moyens pour travailler dans de
bonnes conditions
voilà un message qu'on veut faire passer
est ce que pour terminer donc vous
donner rendez vous le 30 juin et le 14
juillet ce 14 juillet qui devait être
une journée en tout cas c'est ce qu'a
annoncé l'elysée en hommage au personnel
soignant est ce que là vous comprenez
aussi ses convergences que l'on retrouve
au sein de ces manifestations il ya des
gilets jaunes que l'on voit il ya
évidemment beaucoup de syndicats aussi
c'est cette convergence vous vous
l'acceptez cette convergence mais cette
convergence vous l'avons construite
c'est pas qu'on accepte nous l'avons
construit vous savez que nous
travaillons syndicats collectifs
associations de patients main dans la
main depuis maintenant de très nombreux
noirs
donc c'est le résultat de cette
convergence la mobilisation massive
aujourd'hui
ensuite effectivement le mouvement à
l'hôpital et la suite des gilets jaunes
mais je veux dire là le problème c'est
pas les gilet jaune qui sont à l'origine
des incidents les quelques gilet jaune
qui était présent dans la manifestation
ce sont des gens qui viennent dans les
manifestations pour pourrir la fin des
manifestations c'est leur choix
politique
nous le considérons que nous n'avons
rien à faire avec eux il faut que la
police fasse son travail pour que les
manifestations ne se termine pas
systématiquement par ces incidents qui
tourne en août dans les médias français
et étrangers
c'est quand même étonnant voyez d'accord
oui vous
donner la parole pour qu'on puisse
parler nos revendications vous savez je
regarde y compris la télévision russe de
temps en temps parce que j'ai une belle
fille qui est russe
elle passe en boucle dans les
manifestations quoi les incidents en
permanence de trois voitures qui brûlent
de trois scooters qui brûlent voyez
c'est de la manipulation cette affaire
et moi je fais partie de ceux qui posent
la question aujourd'hui est ce que le
préfet l'allemand doit rester en poste
au regard au regard de tous ces
dysfonctionnements qui sont pointés par
les organisations syndicales par les
organisations citoyennes d'avoir
interdit la manifestation et d'avoir
stocké plus de 10 des plus de cent mille
personnes sur la place de la république
samedi
c'est une faute à tout point de vue tant
au niveau de l'ordre trudaine c'est
peut-être pas non plus à l'avantagé des
forces de l'ordre et des autorités de
voir ces images tournaient en boucle un
à écouter ci ça parce que ça des
conseillères les manifestations sade et
considèrent les manifestations
voilà moi je considère que c'est de la
manipulation
c'est de la manipulation pour
déconsidérer les manifestations quand on
parle de ça on prend pas d'autre chose
et ça renforce effectivement les mesures
autoritaires pour qu'elle soit acceptée
par une partie de la population
voilà donc en tout et christophe dans la
problématique c'est la présence
effectivement des black blocks
d'individus radicalisés au sein de deux
manifestations
celle ci mais on a vu également que ça
arrive est très souvent lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune par
exemple merci à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes n'espère urgentiste au samu
responsable cgt on